في عام 2015 ، تم إطلاق CES Asia في شنغهاي
كمساحة لتقريب المبتكرين ورجال الأعمال الآسيويين من
التجارة الصينية بعد
خمس سنوات ، تم إلغاء الحدث
إلى أجل غير مسمى بسبب الوباء ،
لكن اللاعبين الرئيسيين من هذه المنطقة
يواصلون احتلال عناوين الأخبار من
حدث لاس فيجاس بما في ذلك شركة  ربما
لم تكن قد سمعت سابقًا عن
شركة vinfast الفيتنامية لصناعة السيارات ، إنها واحدة من أحدث
الشركات الآسيوية في مجال السيارات الكهربائية التي
تأسست عام 2017 ، وقد كشفت vinfast النقاب عن
خمس سيارات كهربائية جديدة كل منها
ذكية مع خدمات داخل السيارة مثل
المساعد الافتراضي وميزات
مساعدة السائق شبه المستقلة
في فيتنام ، أصبحت
الدراجات النارية والحافلات والسيارات التابعة للشركة بالفعل
مشهدًا مألوفًا في
شوارعها ، والشركة هي شركة تابعة لواحدة من
أكبر التكتلات في فيتنام.
الولايات المتحدة
لذلك لدينا مقر لنا في
سوق إيفا منطقة لوس أنجلوس هو  أكبر بكثير
هنا في الولايات المتحدة ، تقول شركة
فينفاست إن مبيعاتها في أمريكا الشمالية
من المقرر أن تبدأ في أواخر عام 2022 اعتبارًا من
الثامن من يناير ، وتقول الشركة إنها
تلقت أكثر من 24000 حجز
لسياراتها الكهربائية
، وتقول جميع المكونات الرئيسية للسيارة
بما في ذلك البطاريات  يتم تصنيعها في
فيتنام ، جوهر المركبات الكهربائية هو
بطاريات الجهد العالي التي نفخر بها
في القيام بالكثير من الأشياء داخل
الشركة ، وتراهن الشركة بشكل كبير على السوق الإلكترونية حيث
تعلن عن نموذج إنتاج كهربائي فقط
لجميع المركبات اعتبارًا من عام 2022